this is a production of cornell
university
okay yeah so maybe uh might be a couple
of you that have heard me
talk before we've uh actually just had a
thing for master gardeners at cornell on
climate change
um and uh it's the kind of thing i cover
now and then as i'll mention a little
later i've also done
work as was mentioned with the new york
botanic garden in the bronx
with their climate change program i
wanted to mention right here at the
outset we have uh
a website at cornell called just pretty
easy to remember just climate
change.cornell.edu
there might be a couple of you that have
been there before
if so i encourage you to go back again
because it's just this last week i've
released in a totally new
new and much ramped up version there's a
section there called up at the top one
of the buttons is tools and resources
and if you use the scroll down there's a
section just for gardening
there's also a section just on kind of
basics of climate science which i'll go
through a little bit at the beginning
here
and things like craig is videotaping
this today and this will probably be
showing up
posted at that website this presentation
so there's
there's things like that to check out
there lots of good good resources
also i'll be showing some data for new
york and some analyses for new york
what the new york climate's likely to do
particularly for our region
and a lot of it came from it is
available at this particular website for
those of you that are interested
it was a uh statewide both columbia and
cornell university
pretty major project quite a few people
involved and there's sections on
the climate for new york there's sex and
just on agriculture on ecosystems on
human health
all kinds of things there so i'll be
pulling from that quite a bit
okay um so i've got i'm starting with a
couple of data slides it's not going to
be a whole lot of this kind of data
but um when i uh
talk climate change of course it's a
controversial issue a lot of
information out there and i like sort of
i like
this graphic because it puts things in
perspective
about how we live on a planet where the
climate's always been changing
long before humans were here and then
kind of lay over on that what humans
what the human impact
is uh and it's projected to be in just
the next 100 years or so
so this is a very long record this goes
back 400 000
years and the bottom trace there is the
temperatures going up and down on the
planet for you know almost half a
million years
these big dips would be uh the ice ages
that you all would be
you know generally familiar with and
these
uh and there's a lot of little ups and
downs here a lot of
what's causing all of this is been
studied for many years by
planetary scientists by meteorologists
and climate scientists
and in fact one reason we have a fair
amount of
confidence in the climate models we use
to project future climate
is that we can do what they call hind
casting and
actually predict the past if you want
because we know what's going on here and
causing some of these things
for example the big the big dips the ice
ages really have to do with an
astronomical thing
the earth's axis actually tilts a little
bit on a 20 to 40 thousand year
cycle i'm not talking about the seasonal
changes or something like that
and there's some other cycles that
happen on a hundred thousand year basis
that form some of these big
big dips and then you'll see how these
uh there's two greenhouse gasses
so-called greenhouse gases that
uh our inner atmosphere that play a role
today as they have in the past in
warming our planet
methane ch4 and co2 is carbon dioxide
and you see how they kind of track all
of that and sometimes those gases are
responding to
the temperature change and other times
they're driving the temperature change
for example
when due to the planetary astronomical
changes we start coming out of a
ice age notice these take a long time
this
keep in mind the time scale here takes
like 10 to 20
000 years for us to come out of an ice
age the last ice age was about 20
000 years ago and we came out of it
anyway as
the planet starts to warm because of the
planetary
motions and tilt is changing that tends
to melt for example
permafrost which holds a lot of material
that when it warms up
and the and bacteria start working on it
releases methane and co2 into the
atmosphere so it
it just really feeds forward on itself
and speeds up this
that's why the warming is faster than
the cooling
anyway um and then as volcanoes erupt or
whatever where they might produce co2
even before there were humans on the
planet that would tend to cause little
ups and downs
um so you notice here ten thousand years
ago only ten thousand years ago
um still very few people on the planet
but that's about when crop domestication
started
so really as you can see we came up out
of a very cold period and reached a
relatively stable period called the
holocene
and this certainly was you know is
considered by most anthropologists to be
one of the leading
reasons why the human population has
skyrocketed
since that time in part due to crop
domestication farm
starting with gardening and then into
farming and so we've reached a kind of
stable
stable period and to put some of my next
slides
into perspective notice that we'll be
over about
ten thousand years fifteen thousand
years as we came out of that ice age
the temperature went up about eight to
ten degrees centigrade
in that period and we're right about
here now and in my next slide i'm going
to show where we're going in probably
the next 100 years
or so oh
let me show you something else so this
is the co2 trace notice for the past
half million years the carbon dioxide
has been going
up and down between about 200 and 280
parts per million
so my next graph shows that just the co2
thing
but on a different y-axis scale because
i have to
show what's going to happen in the
future and it's going to go way up as
you might be
expecting so here's that same co2 the
x-axis is exactly the same going back
400 000 years
here's the co2 going up and down um
between 200 and 280 parts per million we
know about the old co2
because we have done these ice cores all
around the world and they actually
capture the air bubbles at different
depths in the ice
and they measure the co2 in those
bubbles and that's how we know what the
co2 concentrations were
years ago now we know what it is because
we have a you know a huge network around
the globe
of infrared gas analyzers that measure
the co2 in the atmosphere
and so you know just since the
industrial revolution this is what's
happened to the co2
um so we've gone way off already quite a
ways off
anything we've seen before and the scary
part is to
so we and with you know with what's
happened so far the planet has warmed on
average almost a degree centigrade
or about a degree and a half fahrenheit
and then for the next hundred years
here's what's projected
based on current fossil fuel emissions
so the magnitude
of that co2 rise and also the expected
corresponding temperature rise
is the kind of temperature change that
typically with those ice ages we see
over 10
000 years but now happening in 100 years
so that's what kind of has people
concerned um now of course this is the
so-called there's usually we present
climate data on sort of two different
scenarios basically
not changing much in what we're doing in
terms of fossil fuel use and greenhouse
gases go to the atmosphere
and one moving towards a different
pattern
but what this kind of illustrates i
think is even in the best case scenario
we're
going to have some adapting to do um
to some climate change gardeners and
farmers and
basically every business and every
person out there'll be a little
and every natural species out there have
some adjusting to do
what we want to do though is hopefully
get into a mitigation mode so we don't
go
way up there because way up there
obviously the hudder gets
we get to a point where it's very
difficult to adapt and very costly
okay this is maybe getting down to
something that's a little more familiar
to you the plant hardiness zone maps i
would assume many of you are familiar
with this the kind of things you can get
at garden centers
a color-coded map based on how cold it
gets the coldest it gets in the winter
in different areas
and so of course in the north part it
gets colder and that's different color
code in the south
and these both these maps are designed
built the exact same way the usda does
them looking at the last
15 years of weather station records
for the area so the same kind of weather
stations that give us our evening news
and when you do that you can see that
basically we have this so-called zone
creep no matter where you live
pretty much in the u.s you're in a
warmer
hardiness zone than you were 15 20 years
ago in fact
with the one thing i've done with the
new york botanic garden is about
six seven years ago now we planted a
test garden
of all species that were one hardiness
zone warmer than where they were
to look at how those plants did and
they're all
doing okay um one thing i want to
mention is you know as these zones
change it's not just
what you might you know there's
certainly a silver lining to this you
might be able to grow something in your
garden
that your aunt rose or something grew
south of you
and you always wanted to try
but also you have to keep in mind that
also many insect pests
and weeds etc their habitable zone
is dictated by how cold it gets in the
winter so they're also moving and
there's lots of scientific literature
now showing
indeed things are in the natural
landscape
all kinds of living things are tracking
this
the other thing to think about when you
look at this is while some species are
moving with
with this they aren't all moving some
species are more mobile than others
and so one thing we're concerned about
as ecologists is disruption of important
species interactions so for example
if a prey item of some particular
predator
does move with the climate but the the
predator can't do that then there would
be disruption there
if uh a natural enemy of a of a crop
pest
does not track the pest itself then we
might have some disruption there so
very concerned about those sorts of
things
um this is what really sort of gets to
me is because really my training is in
plant and soil ecology as was mentioned
and um it's really the living world's
already responding so
forget the weather station data i mean
we can really look at
particularly perennial plants are really
sort of like in a way very complex
sensitive weather instruments they
integrate first of all
the winter temperatures because they
require a certain amount of chilling
some of you may know
a certain amount of cool temperatures in
the winter to be hormonally primed
in order to bloom in the spring and if
they don't get that much coolness
they're never going to bloom
and then on the other hand of course
then as the spring does come they kind
of
keep track of the degree days we call it
but basically the heat units
and then that's when they bloom and
anyway myself and a few other colleagues
uh gathered some historical records
going back to the 1960s
of these three species historical
records of first bloom dates and saw
that
indeed on average all these species are
blooming several days earlier
and now the peer-reviewed literature
scientific literature is really
you know just chock full of examples of
this happening
uh around the globe so definitely
something's happening with our climate
i already mentioned this kind of we do
worry about if the plants are blooming
earlier are the pollinators
going to be there keeping up and each
species kind of responds a little
differently to climate change and you
could have some disruption of species
interactions
particularly for highly specialized
combinations
of species so it's a concern and
something else that
ecologists are tracking
one particular thing for the northeast
is that
our winters are warming more than our
annual average temperatures the average
annual temperatures are going up
but the winters are warming more than
the summers and that's a pretty common
thing the higher latitude you go the
more you see that phenomenon and part of
the thing is that
when it's warmer in the winter there's
fewer snow cover days
okay and if you think about snow it's
very reflective
so a lot of the radiation sun rays
coming down
during the winter when there's snow on
the ground get reflected right back
up and don't do much heating of the
planet but if there's no snow there
instead of there's dark earth
it heats up the planet so it's kind of
feeds forward on itself
so anyway pretty surprisingly over four
degrees of fahrenheit
over four degrees fahrenheit warming in
the northeast since the 1970s
that's based on the average december
plus january plus february
temperature and there's the different
dots represent the different magnitude
of warming i wouldn't
put too much stock on that there's
different you know there's a lot of
variation between the weather stations
some of it makes sense some of it may
not
different ways of how the weather
stations are handled but
you don't see anywhere where there's uh
it's going the opposite direction and
it's getting any cooler and basically
it's clearly warming
and pretty dramatically in our winters
um that snow cover thing this is looking
a little bit into the future this is a
map that kind of tries to depict
what the few but the models predict for
our future
the red zone shows the northeast and the
average based on the historical data
where we have historically at least 30
days of snow cover
and the white is showing based on the
higher emissions scenario kind of that
worst case
scenario where we would have at least 30
days of snow cover by the end of the
century
so you know tremendous difference in
snow cover
and what i point out with the deer is
this isn't just a matter for those of
people who care about skiing and
thinking i've got to travel a little
further to
do my skiing but it has an impact on all
kinds of um
things that are really relevant to
gardeners for example
deer i don't need to talk to a group of
gardeners about deer
they're one of the big beneficiaries
there's some winners and losers out
there in terms of climate change in
terms of the species out there
moose are a big loser because they can't
handle heat at all
we're likely to lose any moose it will
probably be very hard to find moose in
new york
within a couple decades but deer benefit
tremendously
first of all the warmer winters they
like that
they can stay healthier but more than
that it's that reduction in snow cover
because they can keep eating for longer
there's more vegetation exposed
and so there's many more twins being
born and just more bigger deer
populations
and there's other reasons why they're
benefiting but that's one of them
it gets even more complicated i'm not
going to go into what this slide is
depicting but
except to say that one of my graduate
students for example
looked at what happens to the soil
microbes the
microbial ecology what happens in the
soil during the winter
and the microbes that are involved in
nitrogen cycling uh in
the winter is affected uh by snow cover
because the snow is actually an
insulating blanket
keeps the soil actually a little warmer
and etc has big impact on all kinds of
things
okay warmer winters
you know i've been called out twice now
by the fruit growers
associations in new york state and
throughout the northeast and in michigan
as well
to talk to them about not heat stress
in their apple and wine crops but why
they've got more freeze and frost damage
in a warmer world and
so one example is what we most of you
probably you know felt yourself in your
own gardens just a couple of years ago
when we had apples a true record breaker
four weeks earlier than normal bloom and
then there was a long window of
you know jeopardy of a frost event and
in fact we lost about 50 to
60 percent of our apple crop across the
state so this premature bloom
can actually cause more freeze frost
damage a few years earlier we had big
damage to some early
merlot some young merlot planting some
wine great plantings
in the state on the other end of winter
what happened was a very warm december
and the plants didn't harden properly
and then we had quote a normal january
and they
they died from freeze damage so um
that was not something i expected when i
first got into this 20 25 years ago but
we now are developing a decision tool
for growers on adapting to climate
change it has to do with frost
prediction
and a lot of apple growers are actually
thinking about putting in different
systems
to protect them from frost damage
misters and different things
still kind of sticking to the new york
area and some
some major trends that we see that are
very characteristic of our area
um each of these bars this goes back to
like the late 1800s each of these bars
actually
represents the average for a whole
decade that that whole decade so like
this last bar here is 2000 2000 to 2010
2001 to 2010. and you can see a very
dramatic increase
in the number of heat stress days
basically number of days over
90 degrees fahrenheit and also another
unusual phenomenon that we didn't really
expect
early on was increase in heavy rainfall
events
not necessarily more rain over the whole
year
but more of the rain that does come
coming down in heavy rainfall
events so we have kind of a heat stress
but also
some short-term flooding events that
are a challenge for our area so that's
um
a pretty major thing and pretty uh
widespread
across the northern hemisphere so
something we have a pretty high degree
of confidence
is you know here to stay kind of you
might say
what the rainfall is kind of associated
with the fact that we're in a warmer
world
basically more of the planet's water is
up in the air as water vapor
because it's warmer and there's more
evaporation and transpiration going on
so when there's an upper atmosphere
cooling event to cause rainfall there's
basically more up there to come down
um this is a little bit of a complicated
diagram but i wanted to show you that
despite
uh more frequent heavy rainfall events
we actually also will have probably
more need for irrigation in the summers
in new york and the reason is simply
because it has to do with the balance
between
uh warmer temperatures and longer
growing seasons
uh causing crops and natural vegetation
and plants in the garden to require more
water
the warmer it is the more transpiration
more
bigger the water needs are the longer
the growing season the more the longer
the plants are out there
and that's kind of depicted here with
the
showing two two different climate
scenarios and how much warming
might have in the summer but if you look
at the summer rainfall it's predicted
not to change much for our area
basically you can't see anything there
because there's no
change so in order not to have more
drought steps we'd have to have
enough more rainfall to keep up with the
increased temperatures if you follow
what i'm saying
so we are a little better off well
significantly better off than many parts
of the world where
the rainfall isn't staying the same at
all in fact it's going way down
so it's kind of a double whammy you know
warmer temperatures
more cropped man plus you're getting
much less rainfall but we're going to
stay about the same in the summer but
still creates a little more drought
stress than we might have seen before
so um those things i just covered were
some things where we have
quite a high degree of certainty i mean
things i think you know when you're
considering what to do in your garden i
think you can sort of count on a lot of
evidence for those things
i'm going to bring up a couple things
here that are a little less evidence
and a little more uncertainty about
what's going on but something just to
put on your radar to kind of
be watching the news and see how some of
this science
gets resolved over time um well the
arctic ice you may have heard on the
news is melting right
and you might think well you know polar
bears whatever i'm not you know that's
not going to affect my garden
but what we have found is that the
melting of the arctic ice
is having an effect on the jet stream
patterns
and so there's quite a consensus now
among the climate science community that
the melting of the arctic ice is
changing the jet stream patterns
where there's a lot of controversy is
exactly how
and why and when and that's
you know still very complicated there's
a paper in
scientific american december 2012 by
actually a colleague of mine at cornell
chuck greene
goes through his his take on all this
and he actually predicts
deeper dips in the jet stream pattern so
that actually if you have a cold front
it could more freezes in florida despite
a warmer world
because of the arctic melting and
slower moving jet streams which means
every heat wave or any cold wave that we
might get
lasts longer because it's slower moving
but there's other climate scientists
that say no that's not how the jet
streams are going to change it's going
to change in a different way but
anyway something to keep in mind
i want to say something about direct
carbon dioxide effects
on plants and this is kind of
interesting to think about
you probably all know that plants take
up carbon dioxide
for photosynthesis to produce sugars to
grow
so co2 is you know there's a so-called
co2 fertilization effect and in fact if
you grow plants
most plants under optimum conditions no
no heat stress no climate change
no insect pests or anything
they'll get a slight to a moderate to
even a high boost
in growth for at least a period of time
just due to the higher carbon dioxide
forget climate change even if there is
no climate change
this is an interesting study done at uh
duke university
this is looking at a down at a loblolly
pine forest and these are huge
tall risers of pvc pipe
as tall as the trees that are perforated
and each of these rings is at a
different you know some different co2
levels
by spewing in uh co2 quite an amazing
you know big big science project
millions of dollars
the idea was to see how does the co2
gonna affect the tree growth and
it did spur the tree growth for a period
of time and then it sort of slowed
that impact slowed but actually some of
the biggest news out of this
was that in the understory in the high
co2
rings the poison ivy grew like
gangbusters
so much so that it really disturbed in a
pretty major way their plans for the
study
and this actually you know has now been
documented that basically a lot of our
most
aggressive fast-growing viney weeds
benefit the most
from high co2 so
that's an issue different plant species
respond very differently so while
many plant species can get a little
boost some will get more than ever it
turns out our most aggressive invasive
weeds
are the big winners in this story
also my colleague lou ziska at the usda
lab
has done some work on use of herbicides
to control
weeds in high co2 environments and
here's just a
picture illustration of one of his
experiments looking at co2 levels
predicted for
near mid to late century this is
canadian thistle
um both of these were infected with you
know plenty of canadian thistle there
and on this side sprayed the recommended
rate of glyphosate
roundup very common herbicide and well
on both sides sprayed
the recommended rate and you got very
little control on the high co2 side
so i had to go to like two to three
times the rate
to get the same control which leads us
to a concern of how will farmers and
some gardeners be adapting to this
spraying more herbicides so you know
there can be
we can't really tie the hands of farmers
as they adapt but we have to be prepared
for
some of these kinds of issues
anyway all of this that kind of ends my
climate change stuff i want to go now
more into impacts and what we can do in
the garden
to adapt and mitigate um
there's you know little question i can't
tell you the details are very uncertain
but i think we can say with a high
degree of certainty that the kind of
climate change we're going and will be
undergoing this century is going to
really change
the very fabric of the natural
landscapes we see out there in various
ways
over the next several decades and of
course this could have implications for
so-called ecosystem services
everything from by ecosystem service i
mean bringing in tourism dollars
for example the maple beach birch trees
are going to be less suitable for our
climate in the future
i'll show a graphic on that in a moment
but also water quality
habitat for birds etcetera it could be
disrupted
as different species come and go so some
now that there's not going to be any
vegetation out there
but some of the existing species will
have to go and others will be coming in
to take their place
this is showing a a study
done basically on on modeling how the
climate's changing in the northeast
and tree specialists knowing how to
model where trees grow
looking at what that might mean for the
trees major tree species mixes in the
northeast
based pretty much on the climate
envelope uh so this doesn't mean this is
really
how exactly how the tree species will
who's going to replace who because it
depends on whether the the seed for the
replacement trees
gets up here and all of that but if you
look at the current situation you see a
lot of gold color that's maple beach
birch that basically says new york is
mostly
kind of very suitable for maple beach
birch and west where we see a lot of
those here
a little green here you see that spruce
fur trees in the
adirondacks there's some of that in the
catskills too
now this is looking at the scenario for
the lower emissions and kind of the
worst case scenario
how that might change and you can see
even in the kind of best case scenario
we lose the spruce fir from the
adirondacks basically from new york
uh that is i can't really say they're
going to disappear
but the the climate will no longer be
suitable for
spruce fur so some of them will be
hanging on they'll be less healthy over
time
and gradually they will be diminishing
the gray that that's replacing some of
this this is the higher emissions
basically we lose a lot of our maple
beach birch
is oak hickory pine so um
but you know our oak really going to
come up here and replace the maple beach
birch i mean
it's anybody's guess if the seeds can
disperse that way plus we got another
problem i told you the deer are
benefiting
they've done experiments and what tree
seedlings do deer prefer most oaks
so you know the tree species that's
likely to replace the maples is going to
get
eaten up by the deer so that's really
not likely to happen just to give you
one example of how complicated it is to
predict the future so all we can really
say is you know our
natural landscapes are going to be
disassembling and reassembling in new
ways and it's not
you know it depends on you can be very
pessimistic about this and get all down
in the mouth or you might just say well
let's you know nature is going to be
changing and it's
you know some you might some things
might be good some not so bad
um natural resource managers i'm working
with the nature conservancy right now on
a climate change adaptation plan for
new york and it's really you know you
can't really manage these days
for keeping the exact same species there
forever right you really have to
have be a little flexible and actually
maybe even facilitate
some other species to come in that have
the same function as a species that's no
longer suitable
so really makes it very complicated for
natural resource managers but
anyway that's what's happening but of
course in the garden there's the same
sort of thing going on right all the
different garden plants you might
prefer some of them will be be able to
adapt to climate change and some will
have to you know gradually
be different species you might be
growing i'm not going to spend time on
this it's just a
that that report i mentioned goes into a
lot of details about what trees are
likely to
benefit gain suitable habitat which are
likely to lose habitat and
it's a lot of information out there like
that
so anyway to kind of set the stage for
what i want to talk about
as i begin wrapping this up towards the
adaptation piece is that
you know for the northeast we're luckier
than some parts of the world where it's
already
as hot as you'd ever want it for us a
warmer growing season and longer growing
season has some potential silver lining
so there could be exploring new species
and new varieties in fact gardeners can
really be sort of at the forefront
of exploring some of that it's harder
for a farmer to do
a lot of experimenting because it's very
expensive and involves their livelihood
but anyway so um there's some of that
but
you know there's some of our favorites
we might have to eventually give up on
and then we are going to have certainly
weeds disease and insects
like we haven't seen before in the
northeast if you think of what it's like
south of here and what gardeners there
have to face that's the kind of thing
we'll be facing
and we're going to have more summer heat
stress than we've seen before still not
as bad as some other places but
worse than it has been here before and
we have the water management problem of
both some flooding events and also more
uh dry dry parts of the summer so uh
nothing that we can't adapt to as long
as we don't go on to that drastic
path but you know something to be
thinking about
this is an interesting example i think
just showing
the case for european wine grapes which
are
you know so important to our finger
lakes area and just showing you
how that affects just within a single
species
vitus binifera how the varieties respond
so this is our current
new york growing season in terms of its
average temperature
and you can see this is why we do good
rieslings in this area and chardonnays
we're right in that zone
but here's what our climate's projected
to be by 2050
so we're really on the fringe of being
able to do good chardonnays but where
now we can do those merlots and cabernet
sauvignons that the napa valley
can do all right and really you know
opportunities
no seriously um now napa valley today
is right about here and what napa valley
is looking at is just the next 30 years
is going off the deep end
and so for the napa valley it's kind of
bad news for
the wine grape industry opportunity for
us but i think this is kind of
illustrative
even for us by the end of the century we
really get awfully hot
even for some of the grape varieties so
but that's kind of what's that's the
world we live in today
so um okay i already mentioned this kind
of you know warmer winters there's lots
of
potential pests that we don't have
because in the winter they get killed
off
includes the fleas on our dogs and
garden pests and everything
these are just examples of a few that
are all showing up more this is a flea
beetle
it's the carries a big corn disease
called stewart's wilt and
so it's a vector for that disease it
used to marginally over winter here now
it overwinters very often
a particular ear iron cornea worm kudzu
some of you from the south may be
aware of that very aggressive it's
another one like poison ivy gains from
the high co2
as well as the warming temperature has
historically kept kudzu south of here
and now it's showing up more north this
is some modeling work we did of the
kudzu
habitable range changing with time so we
go from
current day or short term to end of
century
business as usual kind of a higher
emission scenario worst case scenario
better
and this the dark orange is basically
the kudzu habitable range
you know coming to get us so get ready
um this is showing hemlock wooly adelgid
a big
little tiny aphid-like insect that is
moving northward with climate change
uh being very destructive to hemlock
stands in the northeast
so adapting
so first of all plant selection
diversifying this is what a lot of
farmers are doing and i think it's you
know it's a time in the garden
already to start thinking about mixing
it up maybe a little bit more to
see there might be something of interest
you'd like to try that
requires a slightly warmer temperature
might do better now
and also to head your bets just to make
sure you get you know what you want
because we don't really know what the
you know climate's going to throw at us
the weather is going to throw at us
so experimenting is definitely something
to be doing
in terms of plant selection certainly we
can think about earlier planting dates
more vigilant weed and pest monitoring
and control a lot of things with water
management
besides the idea of you know irrigation
or drainage or moving
your garden to a place that's better
drained or whatever
um just building healthier soils with
more organic matter that gives
better water holding capacity to buffer
you from drought
and better drainage to buffer you from
flooding so doing that sort of thing
that many of you are probably already
doing in the garden
more reasons for that and then frost and
freeze protection for those perennial
plants in those years where we
have jeopardy due to a very uneven
winter and early spring
temperature and commercial growers are
doing a lot about that
in the landscape this is what we saw we
do a lot of our landscape planting
compacting the heck out of soil delay
cement um
and this is the kind of thing if we're
having more frequent rainfall a lot of
urban areas are looking at this is an
issue because it creates more flooding
and all of that
neenah basic at cornell has worked with
this stuff called structural soil which
is basically a mixture of rocks and soil
that allows you to compact soils for
asphalt and cement laying
in urban areas and
but avoid compacting it so much that
plants can grow underneath that
and also that you can't have good
drainage so that's one way
sort of people are beginning to adapt to
climate change at the landscape
planting level also porous asphalt is
another thing
plant a tree getting into kind of the
real
not so much coping with the inevitable
climate change
which is what i've been kind of talking
about so far how do we like deal with it
this is more like being part of the
solution and so
certainly plants take up carbon dioxide
and there's a lot of trees that have a
lot of carbon in them a lot of trees
in uh in new york a lot of million tons
of carbon
all those trees that carbon if they all
were chopped down and
destroyed decomposed or burned all that
carbon go back into the atmosphere of
co2 so
trees are a big storage pool of carbon
so certainly keeping the trees we have
it's an added incentive
to keep those but then also this idea of
planting a tree
sucking up that co2 uh and indeed
plants do you know take up the carbon
however they do lose some carbon
not as much as they take up they usually
store more than they give off
but it's kind of a balance and the bad
news is
for the average of us it would probably
take 20 trees
to take up as much co2 as you emit in a
year
so you'd have to plant 20 trees like
every year to keep up with your
with your co2 emissions um so when like
uh
you know mayors like to say we're gonna
do a tree planting and we're gonna solve
climate change and uh you can if you do
the math and what do we take in new york
city to solve it with
trees but i don't want to be too
facetious
um because actually it's this piece
that's very interesting this has a big
cooling effect
plus the shade of trees and actually
people who've done the number crunching
when you add that in trees have a pretty
substantial benefit
so the cooling effect of trees can out
you know
in terms of urban areas and reducing the
use of air conditioners
um is where the big uh climate change
mitigation piece
uh comes in and the trees i don't want
to take away i mean they do take up some
carbon so they
they place some benefit there but
they're not going to solve the problem
um nitrogen management i want to bring
this up not
you know that many people are really
aware of how big
a problem relevant to climate change
that nitrogen fertilizer is because
when nitrogen fertilizer first of all if
you buy synthetic nitrogen fertilizers
it takes four to six tons of 46 tons of
carbon are typically emitted into the
atmosphere
for a ton of nitrogen manufactured so in
other words if you go to the garden and
you go to the gardening center and you
buy a bag of urea
you just you know upped your carbon
footprint
all nitrogen fertilizers even if you're
using manures or compost
the nitrogen that's in them as it
decomposes and becomes available for
plant roots
there is a sort of a
something you can't control the
microbial activity involved in the
nitrogen cycle releases a little bit of
this gas called nitrous oxide which is
a third very important greenhouse gas in
fact on a molecule per molecule basis
300 times more potent than co2 as a in
terms of its warming potential
and when you do the pie chart on for
example u.s agricultural
contributions to climate change and
global warming
it's not the co2 from driving tractors
or whatever
it's the nitrous oxide emissions from
fertilizer that's over the largest
fraction of the pie
um so anything you can do to be more
efficient
and conservative about nitrogen use
is is probably the biggest thing one of
the biggest things you can do in the
garden
um over three million acres of lawn in
new york a lot of those get a lot of
nitrogen
fertilizer unnecessarily i think part of
the issue is
you know trying to have you want your
lawn to be the first to green up in the
spring instead of letting the soils warm
up
let the microbes go to work that release
some nitrogen naturally
so early applications of nitrogen
fertilizer are you know
something to kind of think about holding
back on mature lawns really don't
require much nitrogen
and we have some guidelines and frank
rossi at cornell 2 has developed
some detailed guidelines on how you can
be more efficient in terms of nitrogen
management on
lawns using legumes you know these are
plants that actually capture nitrogen
from the air and then make it available
to the soil and subsequent plants in the
environment so farmers are looking at
this instead of
synthetic nitrogen fertilizer so i'm
mixing those up in the garden
i'd like to show this slide like when i
go to policy briefings in dc and see how
long
it takes the audience to see what it is
guess what it is
um but i don't know what you see there
but i see
you know nitrogen carbon and energy
that's going to waste
if we don't recycle so certainly you
know using these kind of
organic sources of nitrogen is a big you
know you're avoiding that carbon
footprint
of buying synthetic nitrogen fertilizers
another thing is you know out in the
garden every time you're out there
tilling the soil just like we tell
farmers out there with their big tillage
equipment plowing and mixing it up
do ask yourself why am i doing this and
make sure you have a good reason for
doing it because what you're doing is
really
pumping oxygen into the soil and what
that does
is speeds up the microbial breakdown of
organic carbon
and where does that carbon go but up
into the atmosphere as co2 so you're
decreasing you know the stability of the
organic matter that you already have in
your soil and you're losing it
a lot of times it starts particularly in
agricultural situations with compaction
and then there's this need where we need
to till the soil to avoid the compaction
but then as i say that over aerates the
soil
you burn off that organic matter and
then you have a soil that's less
healthy for microbes the microbes are
very important in creating a soil that's
well aggregated and has good drainage
and you end up with kind of a vicious
circle
so when you're out there in the garden
killing
for example you can till just where you
have to plant the seeds and not the
whole garden
so really reducing tillage you probably
heard about a lot of farmers going to
no-till or reduced still
and part of it is to build organic
matter in their soils but also
it's you know reducing the co2 emissions
so building soil organic matter reducing
tillage using cover crops manures and
compost
all of that stores carbon in the soil
that otherwise would be up in the air
as co2 you've done your good deed
also increases resilience as we said
before to drought and flooding so
kind of adaptation and mitigation
combined
finally while i'm sure many of you grow
some of your own food
you also are at wegmans or the farmer's
market or whatever
buying food and you know think about you
know your choices and how they affect
what farmers do
and there's been there's a big you know
major movement happening now
around the country and around much of
the developed world for sure
of consumers and restaurateurs
chefs wanting to know where their food's
coming from wanting to know how the
farmers are farming
and creating creating a whole back
demand for farmers to kind of be doing
the right thing in terms of mitigation
so finally this is my last slide i think
just
kind of summarizing this planting trees
and other perennials in the garden
all of that does help to cool the
environment reducing human energies and
also sequesters carbon
you know in that woody biomass and that
perennial biomass and the roots of those
perennials so
that's a very good thing to be doing and
i like to say the gardeners
you know you can do less in the garden
and you're doing your part
okay don't be out there tilling the soil
as much as you used to
don't fertilize your nitrogen your lawn
as as much as you used to don't mow the
lawn as often as you used to
use less fossil fuels replace with
renewables reduce use of disposable
plastics all of those things
are really a big part of the mitigation
things
and then of course thinking about buying
local growing some of your own
etc and i'll stop at that
thanks
yeah so every year i kind of get asked
you know by the news media about what's
the this
what's the weather this year what's the
fall color going to be and all that
there are certain
conditions that are supposed to be um
you know characteristic of good fall
color
and um one thing is we had the only
answer i have is that this fall
was truly delayed which is something we
we see more earliness
in the spring than we see delay in the
fall it's more dramatic on the spring
side normally
because we have much warmer winters but
this year we saw a significant delay in
the fall and a very long
warm fall so what happens as
temperatures cool in the fall is the
green color the chlorophyll in the
leaves begins to degrade
just breaks breaks down and so what
actually that does is
there's actually some of those bright
colors that we see beneath like the
yellows and the golds and
reds are actually there much of the time
but they don't really show themselves
because they're so masked by the green
so what happened with the warm fall like
we had the the green color was not
degrading
and it and then when it as it did
degrade it didn't allow it didn't the
grade as fast as thoroughly
to to you know allow that good full
color
but we had some other conditions that
were good we had a good wet early part
of the year so that's
part of a good good fall color
but i think it was just too long and one
of a fall didn't allow that chlorophyll
breakdown
for years we've been actually before
there was even an issue of climate
change
the those who monitor pests were had
developed
a simple winter model that predicted how
bad the flea beetles would be basically
based on how cold they got in the winter
and like i said you know the models all
show basically most winters now
we show more populations than we used to
have so
uh well the allergen so luzisk has done
the work on this and published this and
the
allergenic part is really hard to
understand um
certainly the uh like i said the weed
growth itself is stimulated and
it turns out that in a if we were to
generalize
plant what happens is plants so they're
exposed to more co2 so they
photosynthesize more they get more
sugars in the leaves
but some plants can't find places to put
that sugar fast enough
to keep up with the benefit but those
plants that are really viney and fast
growing
they find you know they keep spreading
same thing like with
an indeterminate tomato versus a
determinate tomato indeterminate would
benefit
more from co2 so these weeds benefit
more but the um
the idea of the allergenic thing is
still poorly understood because it's
actually it's not
you know it's it's not just that there's
more plant there with more allergen
uh it's really you know per unit leaf
area there's it's more potent
and it's not well understood
well you know it's it's funny it's like
it's harder to predict what's going to
happen this winter than it is what's
going to happen in the long term it's
sort of like
you know trying to like looking spending
one day in the stock market and looking
at the ups and downs all day and trying
to figure out what's that going to do to
the economy
what's the economy even like 10 years
from now it's actually easier to predict
that
the stock market will probably be up 10
years from now but to try to figure out
what's going to be an hour from now it's
hard to reject
so this winter you know i think um i
really don't know the answer because
i don't really study that that's more
like a weather issue
and a meteorology issue and art degatano
at cornell is someone who really tracks
it more
there's a way of getting a handle at
least a rough handle on just what it
might be
based on what's happening in other parts
of the globe with the jet stream
patterns
and what's happening with ocean
temperatures that affect when
when for example we get these arctic
blasts and so they can look at something
now
in terms of things that might be
happening in the north atlantic or
whatever
and get some idea what kind of um winter
we're supposed to have
and i have heard the same thing that
we're you know we should could have a
colder winter this year
and i assume it's it goes back to some
of the meteorologists who've been
looking
at those trends we actually are because
i think it's becoming
just more variable though and harder for
everybody to predict and so there's more
um more work going on in uh
in in the area of meteorology to try to
develop better
better forecasting systems because every
it's not so much that we're just seeing
warmer
this and that it's that basically we're
seeing
um you know um
you know climate weirding is what some
people say i mean just
you know it's um it's just getting
harder and harder to predict so
a lot of farmers say it's just that one
in ten years we used to have something
we had never seen
on the farm before and now it's one in
three years and it's not always that
it's hotter it's that
it's the coldest winter and now it's the
wettest summer and now it's the driest
summer and
so uh and that's i think partly because
it's not as simple as we once thought i
mean there's things like these jet
stream patterns being affected and
and all that so
well you know i think you know it's hard
to attribute you know single
weather events and stuff to climate
change i would say for example
that you know more you know as i
mentioned there is this
a real something we can attribute to
climate change is more heavy rains that
can cause some short-term flooding which
could be enough to do some root damage
which could slow down plants for example
uh so there could have been
something like that yeah yeah i don't so
the question is what happened with kind
of like
stunted growth as we uh after the rains
in late summer
and then we saw this long kind of a fall
that was pretty warm and things weren't
growing
yeah i don't really know don't really
know
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu